this is matt bailey president of sight
logic presenting a digital display
advertising primer module one the
digital customer
understanding the digital customer is
the first place to start when we start
talking about display advertising you
see the purpose of online display
advertising is simply to get your
message in front of the online consumer
persuade them to click on your ad and to
take the required action by starting
with that understanding that everything
is about persuading that consumer to
click on your ad sets the tone for
everything we're going to learn
throughout not only this module but
through the entire course on display
advertising and it should also influence
the decisions you make because the
primary goal is getting the user to
click on your ad
because this is online digital display
advertising we start with the premise
that we all understand that people are
using the internet the internet is the
number one source that people go to to
learn research communicate and we can
use that because by understanding how
people use the internet when they're
online can help us to better understand
where and when we can purchase display
advertising and what types of display
are going to work best for the specific
purpose
not only are people online but they rely
on the online medium in order to better
understand what they're going to buy
what have people already experienced
what retailers they should trust which
ones they shouldn't trust which products
are worth while people are going online
to hear other people's opinions about
what products are worth buying
people are also going to search engines
even when they do a search for a branded
product people are going to the search
engine first and doing a search on that
branded product rather than going to a
retailer website or even a brand website
I believe it's because people want to
know the breadth of information that is
available about that branded product not
just through the brand website but
through other experiences who else may
be carrying it for a lower price what
are forums or bloggers saying about it
getting the full breadth of information
about the product before they commit
that seems to be the behavior that
online consumers exhibit prior to making
a purchase they like to research it and
know what it is that they're going to
buy
when people are getting ready to make
that purchase regardless of how much
research they've done the number one
influence that influences the the
purchasing decision is that brand
familiarity and I believe that is part
of when people go online and they do a
search for the entire brand to find out
what is the breadth of information
they're researching what blogs and forms
and other people have to say about that
brand and so that familiarity is very
strong emails are the second primary
influence to the purchase search results
number three and everything kind of
groups together with TV radio print and
we see internet advertising down towards
the bottom but brand familiarity email
and search results are the top ways
online that people were being influenced
to make that purchase
now when we start looking at responding
to online ads typically people don't
want to click on online ads in fact most
users say they don't interact with
online banner ads however we see that
when people see branded information or a
branded ad on the page with an article
about that brand they are more likely to
click on that ad when they see an online
ad within an email that is surrounded
with that brands communications they're
also more likely to click on the add
people will scon sponsored search engine
links if they believe it's relevant to
what they're looking for but people say
they're not likely to click on banner
ads or pop-up ads and then there is a
reason for that the reason is in the
past banner ads and pop-up ads have not
really been truly relevant they've been
off topic they have nothing to do with
the information that is on the page and
so banner ads and digital display
advertising has had a bad reputation to
overcome of irrelevance
however what plays into our favor with
this with new technology with big data
and with online marketing is the third
principle that we're going to look at
that even though people use the internet
they research their purchases they don't
always make a decision when they
research they may come to your site look
around they may be an ad products to the
cart but they have no intention of
completing the purchase or something is
preventing them from doing that in fact
most people will not purchase or make a
decision on the first visit usually only
about two percent of consumers will
purchase on the first visit on a website
so what happens to the other ninety
eight percent of people that don't make
that decision that choose not to add
something to their cart complete the
purchase and move on you see that's when
we need to realize that there are other
things going on within the site people
are viewing information they're looking
at other products and we need to
understand the behaviors that people are
exhibiting so that we can give them a
better message to bring them back to the
website and get them to do what we need
them to do
you see part of this is the obstacle
that is in front of people is that
sometimes when they're trying to search
for information they're getting the
wrong information comscore Microsoft did
some research this year that found that
people have to consistently change their
search words in order to get to the
right information usually about one in
four searches are successful the first
time most times you have to change your
keywords or your search words in order
to find the information that you want
but also not only are people having to
refine their search terms and change
their terms what we're seeing is that
people are taking a longer time to make
a decision and forty-four percent of
search sessions are lasting a day or
even longer because people are searching
and researching for longer periods of
time before they're ready to make that
decision so what can we do with digital
display that will help people make that
decision sooner or to reinforce the
brand der in front of the consumer
during their online sessions in order to
bring them back
well that has to do with relevancy
seeing the right message at the right
time and relevancy is really the key
factor that we're going to be talking
about throughout this digital display
module because relevancy is king for
example if we look at the same exact ad
for a technical device and that is the
sprint wireless card so that regardless
of where you're at you plug this into
your computer and you can go online
wherever you're at this ad on one
website displayed both in the technology
section of the news and then also in the
lifestyle section of the news just based
on placement there was a significant
difference and click-through rate was
clicked through twice as many times in
the technology section as the lifestyle
section that's because the ad was were
more relevant to someone reading the
technology section who love technology
kept up on technology news and so this
ad was more relevant to them than
someone who is looking for news and
information in the lifestyle section so
beginning to understand how consumers
think how they determine relevancy sets
the tone for how we can take advantage
of digital display advertising to
present the right message to the right
person at the right time to get them to
take the action that we need another
step forward in relevancy was taken by
the search engines Google especially
when they started developing their
pay-per-click advertising because the
advertising you would see in the sponsor
is that sponsored ads was directly
related to the words that you typed into
the search box and so relevancy was
heightened to a completely different
level that I would only see ads based on
the words that I typed into the search
box
so the bottom line here is that
relevancy increases conversions the more
relevant your ad is the more you are
going to get consumers and users to
click on your ad so our next few modules
are going to be focused on the concept
of relevancy relevancy based on creative
relevancy based on placement relevancy
based on the content surrounding your ad
because all of those are important
factors to know when trying to reach
your consumer
this has been the primer on digital
display advertising and understanding
the digital customer